[Musik]
als willkommen die fortsetzung folgt aus
der stadtgarten rätsel werder harrach
und erfreute der tropische pflanze weil
ihnen so gut besucht natürlich exotische
tiere oder möchten uns einfach gute zeit
mit dem kind und der familie zu sein
sich aber nicht nur als freizeitangebot
fürs publikum sondern sie sorge dafür
dass bedrohte tierarten geschützt werden
und dass sie sich auch vermehrt der
marion pletzer ihre fehlen muss um 2010
dokumente über zucht bemühungen für
internationales und biskys wiedersehen
mit dem orang-utan marius mit dem ticker
nurejew und mit dem schneeleoparden und
jamila
[Musik]
seltene tiere im zoo zürich ihre chance
auch in freiheit zu überleben ist klein
ein viertel aller tierarten ist vom
aussterben bedroht ihr größter feind ist
die menschheit
gleichzeitig tun die menschen in den
zoos was sie können um diese tiere zu
retten und für möglichst viel nachwuchs
zu sorgen
[Musik]
die erhaltung der gefährdeten tierarten
ist heute eine der wichtigsten aufgaben
der zoos in aller welt es geht um das
überleben dieser wunderschönen tiere
[Musik]
das ist der zwölfjährige sumatra orang
utan carius er kommt 2006 aus dem zoo
dortmund in einer kiste in zürich an
darius wird in seiner neuen heimat
partnerinnen finden die nicht mit ihm
verwandt sind
im zürcher affenhaus freuen sich nicht
nur die tierfans auf den wertvollen
neuling sechs weibchen und zwei affen
kinder mussten seit dem tod des alten
männchens ein ganzes jahr ohne man leben
edition der vorteil darin
verstrickten untereinander
als neue macht trend gehe also wenig
macht einfach gewechselt
sich dringend das jetzt na ja man danach
es ist aber nicht ich finde er benahm
sich sicher familie und hörte zu und
her und das sagen gäbe im kloster oder
barbies reihe wird schon okay das ist
überall so dass gestritten wird und das
bessere ist so wie du
vorerst muss carius mehrere wochen
allein in der qualität station
verbringen erst wenn sicher ist dass er
ganz gesund ist darf er ins affenhaus
die zeit der isolierung wird schwierig
werden für ihn
[Musik]
das ist schneeleopard vieli aus tallinn
er wurde in ganz estland berühmt als
eiscreme reklame
jetzt muss er seinen heimat zu verlassen
die pflegerin lockt ihn in die
transportkiste dort drin hat sie ihn
seit tagen gefüttert ein trick der fast
immer funktioniert
zudem fällt der abschied schwer
sie verspricht viel das eine schöne
braut auf ihn wartet und hofft dass er
viele kinder bekommen wird
das ist sie die schöne braut in zürich
jamila hinkt weil sie als jungtier in
die falle eines wilderers geriet in
freiheit hätte sie nie überlebt im zoo
sind ihre gene zum züchten gold wert
weil sie aus der wildnis kommt bald wird
sie zum zweiten mal mutter ihr partner
ist kürzlich gestorben
jetzt wird der ehemalige star der
eiscreme reklame zum frachtgut
zwei tage wird viel unterwegs sein bis
er im zoo zürich ankommt
sie sind die lieblinge der kinder den
kleinen zoo besuchern ist wohl kaum
bewusst dass auch die schimpansen zu den
gefährdeten tierarten gehören
alle große menschen auf das in ihre
natürliche verbreitungsgebiet sie stehen
auf dem spiel schlichten vergrössern
völker mit den stoß und gewalt das
fleisch einfach in steckt ihnen dann
werdet ihr laden abgeholzt dass es
überhaupt genies bedankt und das
betrifft den 20
diese gehege sind viel zu klein der zoo
zürich hat platzprobleme
deshalb soll die ganze schimpansen
familie in einem deutschen zoo
auswandern
[Musik]
freundschaft aber sie scheinen versonnen
schlechter platz
verbessern sie werden sicher glücklich
fühlen und schon blickt ein wenig gefahr
vor dem moment wo die auch massiv
das wird sehr schwierig und sehr hart
werden für qualifizierung bei uns werte
nicht es ist nicht einfach
manchen hoffte ich muss also
transportieren muss das nord kritisierte
das heißt muss es eine boxerin bringe
dass der arzt auch richtig von
böswilligen trifft das nicht und das
wird schwierig sie das mir vertraut und
in die boxen innenräumen
auch der kleine kappen kubon soll nach
deutschland reisen
[Musik]
und auch bei ihm der nicht betäubt wurde
wird das einfangen schwierig
[Musik]
der orang-utan marius der vor kurzem aus
deutschland kam hat die sechswöchige
quarantäne überstanden er musste betäubt
werden für den transport ins affenhaus
pfleger paul hilft ihm aus der narkose
zu erwachen
er ist nur halbe portion natürlich
doppelt so schwer
somit doppelt so schwer und die kleinen
die angst
nein ich glaube nicht
im norden
ist es
böses weg nach
den kennzahlen los
er schaut einem subjekt erwachsene
zuerst
saarlouis
schneeleopard viele der star der
eiscreme reklame aus tallinn hat angst
nach monatelangem kontakt nur durchs
gitter solle jetzt endlich seine zürcher
braut jamila mit ihrer tochter gut
treffen
[Musik]
roger macht den ersten schritt
gewagt
und zögert nochmals als er jamila sieht
[Musik]
geht dann ganz vorsichtig auf sie zu
und dann beginnt tatsächlich eine
zaghafte liebesgeschichte
[Musik]
für marius wird es jetzt gleich
ungemütlich nach monaten der an
gewöhnung durchs gitter hat affen
pfleger paul bossart beschlossen die
weibchen zu ihm zu lassen einzeln alles
andere wäre zu gefährlich
vor allem vor der begegnung mit dem
ersten weibchen haben die tierpfleger
angst werden die beiden sich verstehen
[Musik]
doch
gewaltig
stravius
carius
[Musik]
jetzt kommt eine nach der anderen mutter
timi lässt sich sogar mit dem
vierjährigen töchterchen am bauch auf
eine rauferei 1
[Musik]
ich finde es gibt doch komisch die
kleine zweier scheint sich zu wundern
was ihre mutter mit dem neuen
familienmitglied treibt
[Musik]
ihm reicht vorerst es wird noch ein paar
monate dauern bis er alle weibchen
gemeinsam treffen kann
nicht immer gehen solche ersten kontakte
gut aus wochen lang haben sich tiger
nurejew und das neu angekommene weibchen
barry nur durch das gitter beschnuppert
doch als sie aufeinander treffen
v
baby
[Musik]
der einsatz des wasserschlauch kommt zu
spät
geschwächt durch die verletzungen im
wasser stirbt berry fünf tage später an
einer lungenentzündung
die vorsichtsmaßnahmen sind enorm als
sich kurz darauf zwei indische löwen das
erste mal treffen sollen noch ein totes
tier einer solaren art möchte niemand
riskieren
der junge löwe roger ist kurz zuvor aus
frankreich in zürich eingetroffen
roger soll sich so schnell wie möglich
mit der löwin joy paaren deren alter
partner gestorben ist
so lässt sich zeit bis sie sich raus
traut ganz wohl ist ihr nicht
auch kurator robert zingg ist nicht ganz
wohl die indischen löwen sind schon fast
ausgestorben und leben nur noch in einem
reservat in südindien und in zoos es
darf nichts passieren
ein kurzes geplänkel
[Applaus]
die beiden umkreisen sich nochmals lange
dann wird klar dass sich das junge löwen
paar mark
[Musik]
da ich das super
bald darauf bringt zwei drei junge zur
welt zwei überleben und sind die freude
ihrer mutter und des zürcher zoos
[Musik]
thema
der zoo zürich will auf die gefährdung
der orang utans aufmerksam machen
rechtzeitig zum presse apéro ist darius
zum ersten mal vater geworden
die glückliche mutter spielt verstecken
mit den paparazzi
darius geht es wie den fotografen extra
will ihm das kleine nicht zeigen jetzt
wo er erstmals zur erhaltung seiner art
beigetragen hat
wenn der verlust von anlagen zu und von
denen die er so weiter geht wie jetzt im
gleichen stil dürfte mehr so 2020 2030
hier die rate im freiland verlieren
kaum sind die fotografen weg zeigt sira
uns den kleinen hd das heißt geschenk
ein geschenk ist der kleine wahrhaftig
es leben nur noch rund 7000 sumatra
orang utans in freiheit
[Musik]
filiz und jamil us liebesgeschichte hat
schnell früchte getragen das kleine ist
ein wichtiger zucht erfolg auch die
schneeleoparden sind vom aussterben
bedroht
[Musik]
heute soll vieles erstes kind geimpft
werden
[Musik]
das ist auch mein spiel zu hause
sein kann
wir haben uci knoten also die raus und
zweimal
und noch einer
die aufregung ist groß im affenhaus im
zoo gelsenkirchen in deutschland
tierpflegerin daniela aus zürich kommt
zum ersten mal zu besuch
ja
schön sie wiederzusehen
und zählt dass die bordkarte sich so gut
man muss jeden tag sind so groß und
traum
deshalb wäre ein traum so sagen
[Musik]
und deshalb sagt
herzig
das haben ja also muss ich sagen ich bin
selber auch erwartet dass man als
künstler gibt es hat ja schon gemacht
und da wähle ich falsch gemacht hat aber
ich kann das christliche einzig
schönste kompliment machen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
bei familie orang utan läuft nicht alles
rund zwar wächst und gedeiht der kleine
hardy abrecht ich doch schon ist mehr
als ein jahr vergangen und marius hat
die hoffnungen auf erneuten nachwuchs
nicht erfüllt er ist noch nicht wirklich
chef der neuen familie geworden
wenn er sich fahren will kommt das
ranghöchste weibchen dazu und verjagt
ihn sie selbst nimmt ihn als mann nicht
ernst
kaum ist die rabiate affendame weg
versucht carius es erneut mit der
willigen tammy ob diese bemühungen
erfolg haben wird sich in neun monaten
zeigen
bei familie schneeleopard steht ein
abschied bevor viele sohn ist erwachsen
und muss den zoo zürich verlassen
ein letzter austausch von zärtlichkeiten
mit mutter camilla
[Musik]
tierpfleger esslöffel lockt den jungen
schneeleoparden mit fleisch in die
transportkiste
ab geht's in einen zoo nach england
dort soll in die wehr eine familie
gründen
ich begrüße mit robert zingg kurator im
zoo zürich hat willkommen hat sind die
transportboxen das ist schon stress
führt ihr wie kommen die ich habe
tiefere wie groß ist jeder transport
jedes handlich von sony will der ist es
stress und nur probieren ist einfach mit
begleitender maßnahmen reduzieren damals
ihr und tischte transparent gewöhnt dass
man sich beruhigt dass man verträgt
flagge mitglied aber das beschlossen
stressen und das obwohl eigentlich eine
neue situation
dass es mehr sozialen kontextes
ethnologie das mit verteilt der laden
zur musik von golden in ordnung was man
kennt neugriechisch
neue lied also psychischen stress auf
dem probiert mit kleinen der maßnahmen
ermöglichen
das heißt man muss jetzt 30 in kauf
eines höheren zielen einmal 20 vor der
ort ist so und man sich nicht einigen so
dass stress wenn es die familie muss
voll oder schimpfen identisch also wenn
es dir familie muss vor den gut aus der
unbekanntes gebiet und auf andere
artgenossen wird verjagt besser als
qualität um größten freiland also es ist
eigentlich der stress aber mit einem
mindest probieren apitz reduzieren und
meinte dass gott im titelkampf das
tödliche vogel hier hoffe dass die
steppe aus gruppe also was ganz genauso
falsch wie honig aber das verhalten von
lorient fettstoffwechsel befremdet einer
sie zusammen gibt es so freundlich ist
dass du dein moment da los gehts
angriffe hätten und auch die unter
häufigkeit der nicht akzeptiert wenn sie
sich auf die hupe gedrückt und der als
präsentiert
und nummer zwei besser und zuverlässiger
be quälten sich auf wasser inhaliert und
am pool in der umwelt ist es richtig
macht oder oder kann man seine
vorsichtige sie kann ist schon mir
vorsichtig sie haben müsste das eben das
risiko
wie oft passiert dass das alte mehr an
den verschiedenen 24 jährige mit
unterschiedlichen völlig und in der
regel auf das relativ gute
vorbereitung sehr intensiv ist doch ein
witz wie berechenbar sind es geht ums
namen schlacht für sie mit dem
entschluss für brass und fürs publikum
das einzige mit erhöhten
heile welt ist auch aus ihrem frieden
und spielt gerne mit kredit oder an bord
mit das gibt seinem freund der kampf
könnte wirklich ins laufen
kurator und zuchtbuchführer was heißt es
kann aber was machen sie also dass für
das buch jedoch wäre also ein super für
ihr recht zuständig für planung von raad
menschen politisch der hat alligator der
zeit christi ziel also sucht gott will
kommt sucht gut dass man die population
hinter große info genetische
informationen versehene bringen das mit
ihr möglichst gut verwaltet das heißt
dass man viele genetische informationen
die next generation bringen das mentale
gemacht mit wärme und werbeform züchtet
wird befürchtet dass mir nur halters
überrascht dass man eine gruppe gekauft
habe und dass ich die hand der
information von verschiedenen zoos in
europa darauf die ganze welt sogar also
jetzt läuft die detail arbeit über
europa sind beim 1 15 unter par aber ich
hatte überblick über alle zwölf taten
zusammen damit ich einen überblick cross
menschen wie oft muss jetzt zu mischen
sondern junge schneeleopard oft
weltreise will raus zucht gebraucht wird
sind täglich so dass wenn sie habe zwei
jahre alt war das im freiland 30 den
vorleser wurde unterscheidet punkt wo
wir vom zugführer einen freien träger
dass die msg und ein gott ein anderer
zum in der regel blieb trat das geht
wenig gefallen was denn um ständige geht
was dazu oft mit der materie hat das
irgendwie showbiz nicht gut funktioniert
dass ein mieter gut aber das 1 4 3 2 und
bisher besteht wenn sie so wenig
exportiert gibt bestätigt
das heißt es zug passiert
wenn sich populationen mit jeder
generation verlieren sie genetische
information und mit dem sucht probiert
man einfach optimale bauliche
zweimal stelle damit möglichst wenig
informationen über zieht verloren gut
aber es ist handlich hauptsächlich
population und das sind möglichkeiten
beschränkt weil der winter wieder zu dir
ebenso zu haben wie das des jahres nicht
so schnell geschafft hat chef oder
separate und
analysen zu dürfen wie sie zweiter gang
ist ja noch mal vater wurde
der junge orang utan darius ist jetzt 19
jährig und endlich chef im gehege er ist
zum mann gereift und ist vater geworden
nach jahren des wartens ist er sogar
doppelt vater geworden mit zwei
verschiedenen weibchen der zweck seiner
reise in die schweiz ist erreicht kleine
orang utans und eine ideale
blutauffrischung für die ganze gruppe
[Musik]
auch die familienplanung der indischen
löwen war ein voller erfolg
das männchen razzia und das weibchen die
sich beim ersten kennenlernen so
vorsichtig umkreisten haben schon zum
zweiten mal junge
das mittlerweile fast erwachsene
männchen kuba und das mädchen kalinka
heute krimi braucht selber für ihre
backstube die einzige wunder tropfen und
sind sind der herz und seele worden
havanna aus dem ersten wurf und kalinka
die beiden jungen weibchen dürfen im zoo
zürich bleiben löwen sind rudeltiere
das männchen kuba wird das rudel
verlassen müssen er wird bald
geschlechtsreif ein zoo in moskau wartet
auf ihn
moment
seminar zeichen dass dahin wenig spanier
im rudel während
upgrades ab sondern vom modell um ein
thema ist des öfteren gesehen
der farbton situation noch zweimal
liegen irgendwo am schlafen oder die
körperpflege momente harmonie
[Musik]
darius gefolgt von den müttern seiner
beiden jüngsten
tierpfleger paul der die eingewöhnung
von marius lange begleitet hat kommt
fünf jahre nach seiner pensionierung zu
besuch
hey
und berührte sie aber
mit punktsieger verbreitet
und den klinisches aprimo und loßburg er
macht immer die gleichen leute sondern
studieren ist
basierten sie immer nur
blödsinn im kopf
und studieren
klarius
und da langsam fahrt gewünscht über
charles dann langsam pater willst du
zack so groß 60 stück
vom rechten magisch
websale die noch studiert
es dauert nicht lange und die alte
vertrautheit zwischen den beiden stellt
sich wieder ein orang utans haben
offenbar ein gutes gedächtnis
bald spielen die beiden wieder die alten
lieblingsspiele
peter hofmann
[Musik]
nicht einmal beim liebesspiel lässt er
sich von der kamera stören der einst so
schüchterne schneeleopard philly aus
tallinn
ein jahr später er ist der liebling der
fotografen
der kleine mohan das neueste kind der
liebe von filet und camilla
jamila ist bereits zum fünften mal
mutter
für viele ist es das dritte kind
man ist erst halbjährig und noch sehr
verspielt er versteht sich bestens mit
vater viel bis er geschlechtsreif wird
darf er im zoo zürich bleiben
im gehege in dem früher die schimpansen
lebten tummeln sich jetzt
kapuzineräffchen
tierpflegerin daniela ist immer noch da
aus gelsenkirchen dem neuen zoo der
schimpansen hat sie post bekommen
sie gebe es entrichtet die boeing sie
hat wie servus könnte auflaufen das
haben meinte hunt das sehr schlimmen
lage erlaubt natürlich ein schönes
gefühl
dass ich das im vordergrund und zieht im
hintergrund
hält rund 1000 boote
selbst der patriarch der gruppe ist vor
kurzem gestorben
ohne
dass
sie
wenig jedem eigentlich
sind halt linda gemacht hat die dir gern
count
aber
wann ist jetzt länger nicht gesehen und
ich hab noch nicht so
hatte ich
habe dann muss ich sagen das habe ich
schönes auto von schimpansen oder kann
wirklich nicht sagen
[Musik]
bei familie tiger geht's wieder fröhlich
zu jetzt ist otto der chef sein vater
nur der kämpfende tiger ist nach münchen
umgezogen
beim ball da lässt cotto nicht mit sich
reden er macht deutlich dass der ihm
allein gehört
[Musik]
foto hat ein weibchen bekommen und ist
vater von drillingen geworden zwei
weibchen und ein männchen
bald werden alle jungen in einen anderen
zoo umziehen müssen tiger sind
einzelgänger sie bleiben nie bei den
eltern
barrios will paul bossart nicht gehen
lassen er lässt ihn nicht mehr aus den
augen so viele junge hat schon angemerkt
wie jene richten wir uns großen da so
wie sie zusammen oder
sechs
weitere selber schon die betroffenen
dabei und das machen für eine schau
gefreut
so viel geht es nimmer vor denen uns das
schöne materie zu hoch wenigstens in
sachen erhalten
[Musik]
lösen sie artlantis
erhalten bliebe was nützt das gerade
tiere die wildnis also das primäre ziel
für die zuchtprogramme ist nicht das mit
der bereitstellung sind das
also ich manchmal schwierig also got
over ob die ladens unter besteht oder
nicht was du solltest gesehen da man ja
wort wie in einer satz population einer
sitzung botschaft und der analyst damit
sie mir etwas verloren gut wenn im
freiland sandri verschwindet sind und
selbstverständnis und das
naturschutzzentrum ist dass man verliert
also quasi glied sensibilisiert und
einerseits im zoo in die er zeigt aber
anders sieht aber aktiv ist vor ort aber
es ist trotzdem denn das sucht business
also business jahr mehr einer pr agentur
für die wilde tier und damit man das
langfristig können machen wir mal da
stellen wir hier und da mal gesucht
bekommen wir langfristig und zu können
fehle jetzt sind wir der heydt der
beliebte rasante also das leopard
babysitter beliebte
qualifikation mit der hierarchie also
der pr abteilung seit 2007
es gibt also eine reihe von top
klassiert sind vor allem einmal gesehen
unsere aufgabe steuer nichts machen also
einer sitzen in umluft dir also stark
fokussiert sondern lernen dort stelle
und dann kam der leittiere hat quasi
präsentieren und mit der leitung hat
aber ganze reihe vorhandene t3 bringen
und aufmerksamkeit auf sie lang als
ganzes und daher durchaus einer die der
platz wird wieder so ein ranking sind wo
man auf drei stopps gemacht und auch mit
eric holder spannender haben 1000 neuen
lehrern oder hätten ihre sache das heißt
die hitparade wurdet ihr gespielte
wichtige rolle das publikum mächtig
sauer
das ist unbestritten in der top 3 euro
betragen die wand sieht das so und der
chance gehabt die präsentieren und aber
im gefolge und bauen es auch whisky
früheren es sind so als reines
entertainment business hier also weit
die ak zum bau dieser vom publikum das
schon sehr verändert wie er laut sich
wie wir findet sie die balance zwischen
deinen zwischen bedürfnis von publikum
und lebensbedürfnisse als züchter
es ist wie sie sagen die balance aus
einer sitz an die bedürfnisse und
identisch mit den bedürfnissen zurück
das heißt dazu muss ich auch entwickler
weil in der wahrnehmung von
gesellschaften wird sich das und eine
sehr mit einem masterplan umsätze sind
ganz neue konzept entwickelt wie man die
darsteller und das läuft parallel also
sowas immer baustelle hat zeigen ja dass
sie eigentlich sich weiterentwickeln
erkenntnis umsetzt einer sitzung zu
dürfen ist ein anderer sitze brachte die
bedürfnisse was könnte es machen
zitierte der freie welt bauen das leben
erleichtert zum beispiel haben in taucht
bald was konkret gemacht es geht vor
allem um die besucher waren es die
iraner sie emotionell abzuholen diese
beziehe könne nur vor dem zdf fasziniert
sie und mit informationen und eine
mickrige aber immer noch schwierigkeiten
mit mit leisen etwas man muss das anders
mit geht das ja in ihrem handelsschluss
beeinflusst hat das immer und zwar wenn
ich das mache das 1000 aus dem fluss der
spieler hat die ganze geschichte und
ölpalme der hetze
entwickle ich jetzt in asien
gut an tangierten dem leben so mobil
sind wir quadratkilometer wie es walter
umwandelt in ölpalmplantagen nutzte das
und der marine seien sibirischen merkt
dass er dem zusammenhang ist eigentlich
verhalten das
kleine filme für ihr engagement
natürlich und auch für die besucher der
messe geworden jetzt nach st die
fortsetzung folgt gott um den
liebestraum und warum der lebenstraum
vom hermann schönbächler
sitzen inhalte der größte andere und
somit natur ganz nah spürt uns asse
indiesem supermärkte und
[Applaus]
[Musik]
persönlich möchte
informiert
werden
[Musik]